chuckle do you still respect people
without discipline interesting okay so
first of all my baseline as a person is
to respect people
that's my baseline now that is not the
same as something we've talked out about
before which is that doesn't mean I
expect a lot from them okay you see the
big difference there
I respect people hey I respect you I
respect what you're doing that doesn't
mean I expect that you're gonna be
humble or you're gonna be hard-working
or you're gonna be brave or you're gonna
even be a slightly deep decent human
being I don't expect any of that but but
I and let me let me phrase this
carefully that doesn't mean I don't
treat them with respect now you notice I
just changed this yes it's not just
about I actually respect you it's I'm
gonna treat you with respect
there's a big difference right I'm gonna
treat everyone with respect but as far
as actually respecting someone um no no
I'm not just automatically respecting
people now I'll treat them with respect
because I don't know who they are I
don't know what struggles they've had in
their life I don't know what they've
been through I don't know that's I'm
gonna treat them with respect and it's
very similar like a jiu jitsu
perspective you don't know I spent okay
jiu-jitsu perspective nogi right you
know good someone is you you don't you
don't and and this is another thing when
you when you know how good someone is
and let's say you're better than them if
you really understand jiu-jitsu you
realize that you're better than them cuz
you've been training longer
fundamentally right of course are there
some people that are just amazing
athletes sure sure
but ninety-eight percent of the people
you've just been training longer than
them or you just were born a lot bigger
than them or a lot stronger than them
but you look at them and say you know
what if this person if we flip this
around and this person be training
longer I'd be the one getting crushed
right so there's that now so so yes I
treat people with respect and my my
attitude is generally to say look I
don't know what they've been through so
I'm gonna I'm gonna treat
way now that being said when someone
just throws away their potential because
they lack discipline that kind of
bothers me I mean it doesn't mean that I
don't respect them but I am definitely
disappointed and in conditions where
there is a gross lack of discipline just
a gross lack of discipline mm-hmm I do
move beyond just mere disappointment and
I do get into the realm of I do not
respect that person because they lack
discipline
so there you go so it's like a respect
meter kind of thing and you're starting
at the baseline yeah yeah I always start
with treating everyone with respect yeah
you're gonna treat everyone with respect
and if you don't you don't know who
you're disrespecting Yeah right
who you disrespect I mean you could be
disrespecting first of all you could be
disrespecting someone that is been
through a lot that maybe you should
learn from you could be you know you're
walking down the street and you
disrespect you could disrespect someone
that's a psychopath with a gun yeah and
now you're in a shootout with them
people are getting you know I mean
you're probably gonna win if you're
trained hard but steadily yeah innocence
might be you know by standards you know
just don't know here you just know who
people are yeah that's yeah bird lesson
to learn from Jitsu men you don't know
how good people already don't know not
just not just how well they trained but
what are they been through that day in
their life yeah you know you've meet
some people in the wrong day and there
could be really a real problem yeah